(playful music)
- Alright, I got a
stain on my button down.
I have an interview today.
I need to get it out.
- That? That thing
shows like no titty.
Do you want the job or do
you want to waste your time?
- I need to the
fucking stain out!
- Wow, not gonna get
it out like that!
- Dude, I'm sorry.
It just cost me 58 bucks.
What was the thing that
your grandmother used to do,
the secret trick?
- Tomato juice.
Juice of tomahto.
- Tomato juice, are you sure?
- Yup.
- Alright. Let me see. Hold on.
- God, I love weed.
- Okay, alright, I
don't have tomato juice
but I have Bloody Mary mix.
- Ooh that's even better.
The horseradish will
exfoliate the stain.
- Awesome.
Okay, here we go.
Okay so do I rub it in?
- Yes, rub it in. Smart. Good.
Is it working?
- I don't know if it's
making it look better.
- Wait you did. You applied?
- Did I put the?
Yeah, you just watched
me do the whole thing.
- I just remembered that
that was the wrong trick.
Tomato juice is
for skunk sprays.
- Are you ki-?
- You know what I
realized her trick was?
A couple drops of
detergent on the stain.
And then you let it sit.
And then you wash it normally.
Do you have time for that?
- Her trick was
pre-treating a stain?
We all know
how to pre-treat
a stain, Grandma!
- Hey! Turn that pout
inside out, sister.
Cause you know what?
Now you have no choice but to
show your freaking titties.
And that's how you're
gonna get a damn job,
in this city,
fucking (bleep) town.
- You think I
could go like this?
- Go like this?
Take the pants off.
- I'm going to interview to
be a docent at the Frick.
- Yeah well your ass is more
powerful than your tits. Sorry!
- Let me just get my bag
and then I have to go.
- Oh yeah, there it is.
Mm get that job, bitch.
- You know what? I am
gonna get that job.
You know why? Cause
I love the Frick.
- Bend over a bunch.
(playful music)